hello and welcome to this video playing
Pablo Morillo with black Pablo this is a
bit bit of an odd line but it's look
catches people of God like hey what is
that and it is not so bad okay this is
not very threatening okay so how do we
how do we play this position yeah I'm
probably in a very classical way I was I
was just briefly thinking if some c5
based approach could be could be
interesting
my ideas to develop at night a six and
then yeah so now I can take after years
castle yeah don't want to do that
perform okay probably become 95 yeah
that's oh no I did not think of this
idea on so what does he want to do f5
[Music]
hmm it's hard to believe it looks a
little bit the structure looks a bit too
odd
[Music]
okay wants to go g4m that is the thing
Quincy eight he will play a five and
then I have a really really strange
piece coordination but he has a really
bad pawn structure these kind of things
are always super difficult to evaluate
now probably threatening Bishop f5
strategically speaking not certain maybe
you can take play g4 in any case I think
f5 has to be played
I have the absolutely worst peace peace
position ever after f5 Bishop d7 the
bishop on the 7s ridiculous and the
knight in particular one c7 is
ridiculous yeah nay yet he had he had to
do it no matter what it was forced so
how do we play that now tonight on c7 is
really ridiculous
I need to get rid of the e5 Knight okay
come on
let's go here
maybe I can play something like Bishop
c8 Knight h7 Queen g5 something like
that and eventually f6
Wow
yeah I was thinking about it and I don't
know if that is good or not wait a
fatigue
I can take her
why does that work
Quincy for sediment
hmm okay
kingi form Wow okay so check and I
cannot take probably queen g6 and f6
okay
hmm it's not so bad
actually a pretty good
twenty-something seconds
[Music]
can you add the Snyder 5 unfortunately
mm-hmm God I know that okay
it's probably a draw somehow yeah it's a
draw
now I don't know I should probably win
this at some point but I also might have
been just worse yeah so a6 is a bit of
an odd line it's not too bad it's been
played by many strong players even by
the world champion yeah so it's fairly
normal I guess
and yeah the engine knows no fear
taking on g3 yeah yeah I don't think
many human players would consider that
you're just like opening up the H file
like that and then play h6 o ok so a 5
get this and take and I mean that must
be somewhat somewhat ok I'm not nothing
brilliant but it should be somewhat ok
but this is how all I do is this is
probably probably a bit risky swimming
here Queenie - yeah and now the engine
wants to go h5 I don't like this move I
thought about it but in in this kind of
situation it's a sword that sticks out
so much can never move the knight and
the engine wants to do the same this is
not a good position but the way it was
that probably also wasn't a good
position Knight a hoorah
Oh interesting
that will be the problem I mean one
issue is that even a simple procedure
like that it was very risky
why does a lot better here a lot better
and it is stronger than Cunha 3 is 2824
I don't quite so checking c4 I've
supposed to be good wow it's not exactly
simple to see
no absolutely not sure if this is really
good for black I mean the engine the
it's probably right here right so I'm
kind of afraid so I took it and he took
Queen takes f6 check King here seven and
now Queen G four wins fled out mm-hmm
yeah
this is the problem and I'm toast
you know said what if that would have
killed me I wanted to do this but this
is just of course winning the exchange
so then this was a mistake quite clearly
in some way here I really should just be
a lot better Jake take somewhere here I
mean that cannot be quite true queen g4
is strong and not repaired or again
queen g4 I guess that is making sure
that I'm on this and he's not easily
having knowledge 45 yeah yeah that's
that's better really this is just 93 is
good now I played this whole part really
badly and here it's very difficult to do
something with black because the king is
always going to be a liability
don't don't think you can do much here
really
no I have to take the draw I mean from a
structure point of view you think I'm
better but I cannot do much really
there's always checking me and snow
summer snow way forward okay guys thanks
for watching